my moment was the headline of the New
York Times after I guess it was the
first or second Republican debate where
Trump had gone on CNN and talked about
how megyn kelly was bleeding after eyes
first whatever okay thanks first and I
and I thought okay well whatever but it
was the top headline at the top of the
New York Times and I thought that is so
strange why is that
to humiliate Trump to some degree this
was just something that you could you
could kind of you know talk about
minimally but to create an entire
narrative over this in order to
humiliate him or to get him canceled was
the the beginning for me of like oh
there's something else going on there's
a secret history year Dave Rubin and
this is the Rubin report quick reminder
guys to subscribe on YouTube and click
that notification button so that you
might just see our videos in your feed
more importantly joining me today is an
author screenwriter podcaster and bad
gay Bret Easton Ellis welcome to the
report they did thanks for having I just
added bad gay on the fly there that's
fun just from our little pre know
everything I've been called a bad gay by
other gays and it's been going on for a
while now so I'm fine with it and I'm
just surprised that you threw that into
the mix of what I do and who I am but
yeah that's been a part of my I guess
reputation for a little while now yeah
alright so before we get to the bad gay
why is this guy a bad gay thing yeah by
the way I'm considered a bad gay - so
you're in good company is not a pajamas
okay that's good when I say bad day
there's a ton I want to talk to you
about you're one of the short list
you're on the short list of people that
I think relatively makes sense in 2020
right which is a very high compliment as
many people think I don't but I'm glad
that you think yeah I do I don't know
what that was about me but what I want
to start with is you are actually from
Los Angeles and for a los Angelino as
they say you grew up in Los Angeles I
know how it framed a lot of your work
yes you just talk a little bit about
what it's like to grow up in the
really bizarre city well I think it was
perhaps less bizarre in many ways when I
grew up in the 1970s I was born in the
60s and basically my childhood was spent
here in San Fernando Valley and I think
it wasn't necessarily that the geography
of LA was so special though it was
growing up someplace where you can get
to the beach in 20 minutes and then the
mountains in an hour and then the desert
in 90 minutes was kind of a very special
magical place to grow up there's a lot
of freedom out here there's a lot of
freedom also for a child in a teenager
because of cars and mobility and the
freeways and once you get that driver's
license at 15 and a half your learner's
permit then you're off and running and
you have all of this space to explore
and that was what was so wonderful about
growing up here in Los Angeles during
that era I think the other thing that
was special about it was just special
about being a kid in the 1970s and that
was again an emphasis on freedom a lot
of freedom I barely saw my parents
maybe my mom more so than my father who
was you know a nine-to-five guy worked
at firm downtown but I just remember
especially now knowing so many parents
who have a kind of lockdown feeling
about their children that it was kind of
amazing how much freedom we had and how
that freedom aided us in growing up and
slowly moved toward adulthood and I
really cherished that and I really loved
that sense that we were left to our own
devices no parent was hovering over us
making sure we were doing this or doing
that and that we had all of this room to
roam and and also just to like I don't
know read whatever we wanted to read see
whatever movies we wanted to see and
also in that decade things were really
not made for kids it was an a culture
that was completely made for adults and
as a kid that's where you navigated
yourself through and you really learned
a lot about the secrets of the adult
world the world that you really
want to move into so that is kind of
what I remember from my childhood both
on just just as a human being and then
as a kid growing up here in LA yeah so
that's why I wanted to stay here because
I think a lot of that it's very obvious
that that framed a good portion of your
work but then also when you see now the
way LA has become and because it
political correctness and everything
that seemingly is so wrong with society
that it's it's see it seems like it all
comes from right here it must drive you
crazy like you know we can't have hosts
at the Oscars anymore for a place that
used to be edgy and free and artistic
and all that good stuff well look that's
not just LA that's pretty much
everywhere and it really is in
particularly in the entertainment in
ron's of you know the west coast and the
East Coast that that's just where we are
right now a kind of corporate culture
mentality in terms of like the Blanding
out of the culture of making no one is
offended and all that stuff no I mean
I'm I'm kind of disappointed in many
ways at how the narrative turned out
from my childhood of freedom in the 60s
and 70s and even into the 80s 1980s
being an artist and how important it was
to have a voice that was uncorrupted by
corporate hands let's say and that you
had the freedom to tell any story you
want it to you know cultural
appropriation hadn't yet existed so my
disappointment isn't necessarily in
California politics and how they have
kind of ruined a lot of of the state but
more more or less a this mindset that
says we all have to act and and be a
certain way that's the thing that I miss
most and when you say that about yes the
Oscars that we can't have a host because
first of all who wants to host it and
second of all they'll Google you if
you're the host and they'll find out
I've said this sometimes 17 years ago
but um but no that's that's a cultural
thing that is really part of what and
I'm not gonna plug the book but what
white is about white really is about the
trajectory of being a Gen X guy who had
all of this freedom and this sense of
pasa
ability about expression and expressing
yourself and then ending up in the
summer of 2017 or 2018 but what the hell
happened what happened to all of that
and where did that go
yeah how much of your sort of view on
all this is shaped by being a bad gay
that gays are sort of outsiders
off the bat and that does a frame how
you kind of look at the world a little
bit completely yeah well look it's what
I think made me want to be a writer in
many ways I think being gay as a kid
then I'm not so sure now I think it's
probably a lot easier and you're a lot
more what's the word acclimated into
culture in a way at a much earlier age
than we ever were I'm a bit older than
you but growing up in the 70s and into
the 80s you were kind of a secret agent
yeah you were secret you were not out
and you had to kind of navigate these
paths on your own one of the things that
I think is really interesting about
being gay is that you have to I think
you look at the world and a much more
realistic hard way than your straight
counterpoints to I think that you see
the world for what it's really like
you're not really involved in the poses
and in the game and ship that goes on
within you know societal structures and
you also have to you know redefine most
everything that you experience
culturally whether it's movies whether
it's pop songs whether it's things you
watch on TV whether it's books you read
so you really begin to you begin to see
the world in a way that none of your
other friends do you are an outsider you
are an outsider because of that but I
also have to say that I did not let it
define me and it was not something that
ever got me down I never got depressed
by it it was something that I realized
was just another thing I had to deal
with I'm on many other things I had to
deal with it was not of and I think this
is probably where I was not that
concerned with it and it became
something that was you know I resented
the fact that I couldn't express myself
in a certain way and I think that
frustration certainly played a part in
wanting to become a writer so I have to
you know thank you it away I mean it
kind of worked for me oh yeah but when
you see what sort of has happened to the
gay community where it used to maybe in
the 70s and 80s and before that there
was a subversive nature to it a lot of
good art and music and underground
scenes all writing and writing and all
sorts of things came from it where now
it seems like it's so the reverse it's
the most sort of woke you sort of
cemented bland bland way of thinking
well in terms of mainstream you know
whatever the hell that is but I have to
say that's true of everything and it's
just that what happened last ten years
is that gay life whatever that means and
I do believe that there is a certain
aspect if you're a gay person that you
do have a bit of a gay life it doesn't
mean that it overwhelms you and
everything becomes gay it means that
yeah sure you have the same
preoccupations and some of the same
concerns as fellow gay people you
obviously have to in terms of 20 years
ago politics or even further back than
that how the United States was dealing
with the AIDS crisis for example so you
you are you are pushed together to a
degree but I I think that that's
happening all over the place I do find
it distressing though that the gay
community and I and I have gay friends
who hate me even using that term that
the gay community they really resent it
but there is a gay community I live in
West Hollywood I see it on the boulevard
all the time but I think the problem is
that that is happening everywhere and I
do think that I would love it if the gay
community listed more to someone like
Morrissey who was constantly criticized
by the gay community for just being open
and honest and saying what he feels I
don't think he's attacking anybody he's
just he's not really on the right side
of the political curve for most gay
people and I and he's automatically
attacked now that is really true for a
lot of people I wish that was pulled
back and I wish that the conversation
was once we're open it just isn't right
now and that is that is a problem but
it's not just affecting the gay
community it's I think everywhere yeah
do you see that as sort of a direct
offshoot of what identity politics has
done if you don't identify enough as
gay or the new thing is that you can be
gay so there's like a like a Peter teal
peebo dodge edge maybe the way we are a
little bit version of gay but we're not
queer sort of right like we don't
prescribe to the whole set of ideas it's
not enough to be an out gay person
living in West Hollywood
right you know from LA for you know 50
years that's that that then quite get it
but yeah yeah but you have to understand
I kind of made my way through that in
the 80s as a young writer and I knew I
was in what I call the glass closet
meaning everyone I knew knew I was gay
and I had a partner when I talked to the
media account [ __ ] back in those days
basically if you came out and you were a
gay writer you were get a wise degree
you were put into the gay section of
bookstores I don't think they have those
anymore I'm not sure if they do but they
did have them and it meant a kind of
death in a way for for for a mainstream
acceptance right so even if you weren't
writing about gay things specifically
what sort of you were gay oh uh right
look I was on the gay channel on Sirius
XM it was ridiculous I didn't want to be
on the gay Channel I wanted to be on any
of the politics channels I write them
put me on the left channel put me on the
right channel the other channel anything
but they were like well you're gay right
what do we do at the game wait exactly
which is the problem and that is what I
always resisted because I knew I was so
much more than simply gay or we're who I
wanted to have sex with I always knew
that from a very early age that I was a
writer that I was a person that I liked
movies that I all these things that I
wanted to do and then there was gay
somewhere over here and I never felt the
need to make that the number one aspect
of my identity I don't even think I
could even came out to anybody it just
sort of happened gradually oh you're
bringing Jim to the party or Oh Jim's
coming for the weekend or whatever and
that was how it was I really didn't
think that anyone kind of what I deserve
a tearful coming out for me and I never
even felt that now that's not to say
that people needed to go through that
narrative and that's and that's fine but
I just didn't tie myself into with a gay
identity and so I do think that that is
a problem but again not just don't not
just for gay people but for people of
color for women it
really had but I also believe Dave that
this is an online problem in a way there
is an offline world after an office
nothing still exists which are we right
now
well we're I think we're having an
offline conversation yeah I hope I live
my entire life offline to a degree even
even when I'm online and I had them and
I've got into a lot of trouble over the
past decade or so but I think there's an
offline world and I am I'm part of it
and I know that the way women and men
and gay people express themselves are
very different than how they express
themselves online and that is kind of
where we're at right now and I think a
lot of people are too afraid to say
things that they say offline online and
we'll just see where this note plays
itself out so it's funny you bring that
up because I was gonna mention a little
bit later so this is jumping ahead that
American Psycho it's almost to me which
was your third novel right it was the
third moment um that it's like we're all
sort of behaving like American Psycho
you know like we're all sort of the same
in the functional world in the real
world right and then everyone with their
secret avatars and their anonymous
accounts or whatever is a psychopath
online so like it's maybe maybe there's
your sequel or something well that's
really interesting I mean I I talk a lot
about the creation of American Psycho in
the book white and for some reason it
haunted me because it was something that
I really thought was going to be the
strange experimental novel that maybe
3,000 people read I thought it was so
weird so out there so super violent and
pornographic that would never forget
misogynistic because it cost you some
slap misogynistic I'm not saying that
I'm saying what racism yeah I'm
massaging just because there's acts of
massage and he doesn't mean the book is
massage of course so so I really didn't
think that many people were gonna read
it but I also think that one of the
reasons why it still look popular today
and still in print and tons of people
read the book a lot of it has to do with
the movie the movie definitely made
people re interested in the book was
because Patrick Bateman is kind of a
curator of his life in a way it's very
much the way people are now I mean a lot
of Americans like it was all
as if Patrick Bateman is showing you a
series of selfies on Instagram he's
constantly described in his life and
what he's wearing and what he's eating
and where he's going and what restaurant
is that ad and what ditches he's eating
in the restaurant it basically is how
people treat their lives today from this
kind of like almost God's eye view of
you know not living or participating in
it but actually just like photographing
it and and you know curating their life
rather than living oh yeah and what
about the part about having sort of two
separate lives in a way because that's
what seems to me people are doing online
right now well that is true but you can
also um you know I I have I don't know
if I have a lot of sympathy for that it
kind of is frustrating to see people do
that but look I know a lot of people on
Instagram and do that I you know I
talked to my my partner sister who one
morning was extremely depressed they
were on the phone and she was just
complaining about her life and hello and
happy she was and then you know 15
minutes later she took these great
Monday looking forward to the week so I
don't know I mean I think people are
complicated and I think you know people
are basically wrecks a lot of the time
and I think that social media gives them
a chance to make them feel better about
themselves to a degree yeah but I do
wonder if there is if the ties are going
to turn and we are going to have a more
realistic authentic social media or if
maybe it's just not possible yeah it
because of the medium itself yeah it's
interesting I mean I think some of us
are trying to fight through it and do
something more authentic and and be a
little more real thank you sir
yeah well I I try but it's like you have
to like kind of try to do it as opposed
to just waking up and right you right so
you're a stalker much less yeah IIIi
tweet I tweet my podcast yeah at a case
they'll make a joke about I don't know
what I'm gonna talk about the
coronavirus we can go and then people
thought it was racist so it's sort of
like it was a Doge it was a Doge meme
you know one of those remember those
dogs yeah and was going oh he's ordering
some bat soup and then saying oh I've
got the bye room
or whatever something you were being
anti-aging anti-aging yes because the
Doge was buying the bat soup from a dog
that had an Asian moustache you know
whatever and got a lot of racist racism
from that so I don't do it I don't I
don't really do it anymore
it's I don't really care I'm older it
doesn't really that matter that much to
me I have a podcast I can say a lot of
what I want to say on the podcast
without having to be careful about how
its worded in a 200-word tweet and so
that's one of the reasons why podcasting
begins to seem so interesting to me
because you could place everything
within context in a way that you
couldn't you can't on social media yeah
are you not surprised then that people
actually care about this sort of thing
what's because it's like well meaning
conversation like actual just decent
conversation where if you watch
everything on mainstream media and the
sound bites and everything it's just
like we're getting clubbed over the head
and then it doesn't seem very like
people always say oh babe it's so great
you bring people in you treat them
fairly you have nice conversations blah
blah blah and I'm like this is not
rocket science this is also not the
mainstream media yeah
and my podcast is not mainstream you
know that's what I mean that people are
starving for something oh I certainly
think that's what podcast blew up that's
one reason why podcast pull up and why
as becomes it's a popular thing because
because of its authenticity and that it
is two people having a real conversation
compare it to I mean I really don't I
don't understand get into the
combinations they're all here and I
needed to do them in two minutes at each
you know that's what the gotcha
questions they're all in I'm finally
gonna say I love gotcha questions I love
that when you walked in immediately you
were like Dave whatever you want to do
yeah whatever you want to do is to have
fun but I do think that it's hard for me
to watch people and talk shows now or
morning shows promoting whatever they
are and pretending to have some kind of
real conversation it's it's it's a
unfathomable to me that anybody can do
that let alone read a magazine article
about a celebrity
it just seems like because they're so
neutered yeah one of the things I've
been thinking about lately is when I go
on my book tour for my first book so
you've been through this rodeo before
yeah is that I'm gonna have to go on
these shows and it's like the idea that
I would have to change from this mode
which is just me being myself sitting
across from you doing it you know
time constraints the rest of it versus
now go on all those shows between
commercial breaks the pointed questions
you got to get somebody you've riled up
about something like that actually gives
me a little anxiety versus like you want
to just talk about whatever you want to
talk about for as long as you want to
I'm good to go but you can do it
offensively yeah because I hadn't been
on a bookstore a book tour for 10 years
and I went when I went on one last year
and I'm still kind of on it and I I was
shaky at first not doing it for 10 years
2010 to 2019 a lot has changed and so I
kind of like I got used to it and I
figured out how you do that and you stay
on authentic person also I have to tell
you a lot of it was print and the things
that I did that were media were was
surprisingly I mean look I did a lot of
mainstream stuff I did Bill Maher I did
stuff on Fox yeah but a lot of the
mainstream media didn't want to touch me
so that was something that I really
didn't have to worry about it a little
bit different in England a little bit
different in France but when I did the
mainstream stuff the talk shows I was
just myself and people liked it people
liked it I think that's what you have to
do people can smell in authenticity and
part of the problem now is that and my
partner I talk about this all the time
is that how do you survive in this day
and age without being authentic you
can't you can't really do it you might
have been able to do it ten years ago
and done your pose and said your
scripted lines it just doesn't work now
people smell it and that also means that
you will be hated by a lot of people and
you just have to live your life and let
the cards fall where they may and that
means maybe you're not gonna get that
job or be on that show or whatever but
you have to be able to sleep at night
yeah it's interesting because one of the
things that I like about that sort of
pressure of authenticity maybe that's
not the right way to pressure but like
the it constantly forces you to reinvent
yourself in a way because it's like if I
give a talk and then I give the same
talk the next night which I never try to
do I'm always trying to push myself to
change it and feel you know really just
like what am I really thinking right now
or like did I think this and now I moved
it forward a little bit or did did this
thought go the other
or whatever and that's actually good
creative but you're also undoing that
when you say that kind of naturally yeah
I'm not really trying that you're even
thinking about that it means that you
are concerned about this and it's coming
too naturally I don't think you're
sweating it necessarily because I feel
the same way I feel that I I don't know
I feel that I've been able to adapt in
many ways and want to adapt to what's
going on in the world and my career is
very different now than it was at one
point and I also think it's hard to keep
a career going that long without
adapting without adapting I mean it I
think you're stuck in a kind of stasis
and that you that as an artist or as a
creator that you want to add add that
it's it's something that you want to do
that it feels natural but if this is
making sense
make sometimes I'm kind of there so you
mentioned cancel culture before and then
I brought up the the charges of misogyny
related to American Psycho yeah so I
just read on your Wikipedia and if it's
on Wikipedia it's got to be true that
you had the deal for American Psycho
with Simon & Schuster but then because
what was it women of now or the now of
women or the something they accused you
of being misogynistic
and I got in and then was the book
dropped I mean this is sort of an early
version of canceled calls oh it is it
was I am NOT that story up for me I got
a big deal at Simon Shuster
I turned the book in this is a long time
ago
in December of 1989 and throughout 1990
the book kind of moved through the usual
runs of the latter that it does through
a publishing house getting copy edited
we figure out a cover you're at you're
editor does some basic editing on it but
there were people in the publishing
house were very offended by American
Psycho usually assistants young people
working in in the in the publishing
house and leaks started happening leaks
of some of the most violent passages
were being sent to the press and certain
members of the press and so suddenly it
became a story and the book hadn't been
published yet but it became a story and
it became more and more controversial
the more and more that these notorious
scenes were leaked
of course out of context they're
horrible and so anyway the controversy
got louder and louder and louder and yes
kind of like today in a way Simon and
Schuster
collapsed and said we are not going to
publish this book because of the outcry
in the media now this is another thing
that happened then is that it was
actually the corporation that owned
Simon Schuster that demanded the
cancellation it was Gulf and Western who
owned Simon & Schuster and the head of
Gulf and Western did not like the
controversy did not like the fact that
his his corporation was being blemished
by this book who ordered the
cancellation I knew the head of that
company of Simon Shuster quite well and
I knew that he wasn't the one who
cancelled it but he was the fall guy he
had to take it so anyway that is what
happened it's a happy ending because a
better publisher picked up American
Psycho and they published it a few
months later and you know the rest is
whatever it is right so it definitely
meant happily and the movies made
everybody know say one thing that's very
interesting is that Tammy Bruce was the
head of now who was the most against
American Psycho she was my nemesis then
in 1991 and now that's hilarious I don't
know she's on she's one of the leading
lights the bright lights and Fox
actually and so I I don't know I find
that kind of ironic in the way that the
culture works I mean that fits so much
of a lot of stuff that we've talked
about privately because the what I've
only met Tammy Bruce once it was at
david horowitz freedom center thinking
david horowitz was a famous lefty
children of communist who then you know
became became you know conservative yes
and with his conference he did a thing
on sort of the new generation of former
lefties that have sort of woken up and
it was me Tammy Bruce Candice Owens and
a couple other people's that's the only
time I met her and it's funny she was
opposed to you back then and right here
that's actually a great segue for a
little political stuff where are you
politically I mean I have a sense of
kind of where you're at and and
everything these days feels sort of
amorphous but you know what I was ever
political person I just wasn't maybe it
was because I was privileged to a degree
and politics just didn't interest me why
would they I was a privileged white kid
and moving from high school into college
during the Reagan eighties everything
seemed whatever I mean I kinda guess I
complain about Reagan mindlessly like
all of my other kids of my class and a
lot of people took American Psycho to be
a book that was critical of aliens of
the Reagan eighties and it was critical
of some of the cultural values certainly
about greed and about yuppie them but
I'd end up beef with Ronald Reagan I
mean that wasn't part of what that book
was about some of his iconic iconic
iconography is used in the book but you
know that was just he was just the
president during the time that that book
took place and then you know I was
living with someone for a long time it
was very invested in politics actually
ran a couple of gubernatorial campaigns
in the 90s and I got a close-up look to
that and I just hated it I just hated
the whole notion of how was all played
out and none of it interested me and it
really and I I during the Obama era
everything's fine I mean I wasn't really
paying attention something happened with
Trump something happened with Trump that
I think has happened to all of us to one
degree or another something was
announced and I again another
presidential election cycles coming up
and I'm kind of following it but
suddenly I'm following it because it's
very interesting to me how the media is
treating the Donald Trump narrative now
I'm talking about a media that I had
been following closely for 30 years and
trusted someone the New York Times CNN
New York Times and CNN all of my life I
read them and I trusted them and I
believed in them and it was all they
were you know and I began to think that
they were missing the story that they
were going off a different path that
really wasn't the reality that wasn't
the reality that there was a new
narrative that they were for me and this
began to bother me and I don't know why
I hear yeah I don't know why I am I'm
nonpartisan I never saw myself as I
never saw myself really if I saw much I
think we have a similar trajectory I
think that I was a liberal guy who was
gay and was you know rightly so rightly
so it was fun
not never stridently never far left or
whatever but I know
I believed in the good fight on the
liberal slide something happened I began
to see that this sign was curdling do
december do you remember a moment cuz a
lot of I do a lot of people have like V
moments yeah what was my my moment was
the headline of the New York Times after
I guess it was the first or second
Republican debate where Trump had gone
on CNN and talked about how megyn kelly
was bleeding after eyes first whatever
okay thanks first and I and I thought
okay well whatever but it was the top
headline at the top of the New York
Times that is so strange why is that
to humiliate Trump to some degree this
was just something that you could you
could kind of you know talk about
minimally but to create an entire
narrative over this in order to
humiliate him or to get him canceled was
the the beginning for me of like oh
there's something else going on there's
a secret history here and that is how I
began to become somewhat radicalized in
a way from who I thought I was to where
I ended up being and again I have to say
I'm not a partisan I I still am someone
who is loath to vote I'm in the majority
of this country and yet what I've
noticed didn't mean you didn't go to my
dumping my dumpy polling station over
here where I'm pretty sure I contracted
gravity you were there yesterday no I
was there and I'm not going to be there
either but I so but I what I found so
interesting and really what white a lot
of it is about is about how I saw the
left begin to disintegrate and a part of
the aisle that I thought I was on I was
I thought it was in that part that side
of the theater and I realized that I'm
not and I don't want to be on this side
of the theater if it is this hysterical
this crazed and it's and also I really
hated the creation of narratives that
were obviously not true that were being
used to undermine a legally elected
president whether I liked him or didn't
like him I just thought there was
something so distinctly unamerican about
the way the left
creating their stories that it just
began to unnerve me yeah you know what's
super interesting about that that David
Horowitz who we just mentioned when I
had him in here he's a huge Trump
supporter and I asked him do you have a
moment when that happened and he
mentioned the megyn kelly bleeding line
because he said for him as someone that
had was a conservative but was love but
didn't understand the Trump thing he's
like that moment got it for him because
he because it was basically Trump being
like screw all of you I play by none of
your rules so that same moment that sort
of had you wake up from a media
perspective as a lefty for him as a
conservative was like that was why he
loved Trump but it's so weird because
yes the Trump screw all the rules guy is
what everyone loves that's what
everybody loves yeah and it's so
interesting that yet on the other side
is what a lot of people are horrified by
who would normally like that supposed to
be a person right and yet because it's
Trump and this is the problem with Trump
and I talked about this again in the
book it is about I believe it's about an
aesthetic it's about this guy and what
he looks like and I always have said
that if Trump was in the package of a
Mitt Romney it might be more palatable
for a lot of people and we certainly
would not have this kind of like what is
truly I believe Trump derangement
syndrome
I believe it's purely physically you
also need some of the language the
tweets there I think even look my mom is
a huge Trump supporter as is my stepdad
has a lot of friends of mine and that is
the one complaint that kind of comes up
that they wish he was that he would take
things down a bit
though I don't believe I don't believe
that I believe that is exactly why they
like him and that again it's that kind
of like well I
it proves that you're like a better
person that perhaps you really are too
safe well that's what I always think of
sort of the never Trump liberals or the
never Trump conservatives it's like he
did all the dirty work he had to do all
the tweets and all that stuff and then
he won yeah guys just always lose yeah
so it's like no let's eat a crap on him
so you can still go to nice parties no
no but it really is I think part of the
problem is that for some reason Trump
just I mean I still hear it from people
this
notion and they're still not over that
he's not presidential I think people are
talking like it's 2015 I think
everything has changed a lot of things
have changed about the presidency under
Trump he's really you know he's he's
been the bull in the china job and you
know he's still there
and he's still the disrupter which is
what a lot of people wanted from it what
I don't get on the other side and
believe me I live with someone who is a
far left Bernie Sanders supporter who
really crumples at the thought of Trump
or seen him on TV every night just
completely loses his [ __ ] over Trump I I
just don't understand where there wasn't
a moment where the kind of cunning
didn't come in to liberal thinking about
how to deal with from that instead it
was just pandemonium apocalyptic
hysteria
yeah it was everything let's create the
Russian theory let's create this let's
bring stormy Daniel let's bring Michael
have a night let's do all of these
things instead of I think just finding
that perfect southern leftist who could
kind of like play with Trump on his own
field I like have a nice sense of humor
because quite respectable and great and
I and I think basically and I think part
of the problem that happened during
those three years was that the left
became fractured became over they lost
judgment that's what happened they lost
judgment with Trump because once you
start getting that hysterical and you
start making up all this stuff you lose
your judgment and I think that is
ultimately where they are now and but
again we'll see how it plays out but a
writer well as a writer though is Trump
like in a way like the most perfect
character that someone could ever come
up with because of that because of his
ability to have so many people have
completely polar opposite reactions when
he says one thing and you can and if you
look at Twitter and it's like one person
heard the end of the world and one
person heard the messiah coming like
that as a character for a writer must be
like whoa that's what i want to come up
well look i'm i am a fairly positive
person so if those people here the
messiah coming well they are
like I mean I think the other side is
deaf and blind to whatever
Trump offers the other side that's the
problem the conversation isn't happening
it is so one note on one side in terms
of understanding Trump of getting out of
your bubble and understanding the appeal
of Trump if you're not able to do that
you're dead you're basically not you're
gonna be a very unhappy very miserable
person but that's also why I see a lot
of people that I thought were pretty
relevant a couple years ago politically
and socially that now seem crazy to me
although they've been unable to
recalibrate after this or at least see a
little bit of something that other
people saw I'm reading this book called
antisocial by Andrew Morales he was a
writer for The New Yorker and it really
is about his hellish descent into
started with the deplorable at the in
Washington inauguration in 2017 and and
and and trying to figure out all right
people like whatever Mike sort of Achor
you know Milo or and and it really is it
really reads like a lot of stuff in The
New Yorker in a very musty way like
we're still in 2015 and you really are
still lost kind of complaining about
things that we've all kind of moved on
from anyway and I see the left kind of
stuck in that in that pocket
that there's still you know thinking
about things that have long been
dismantled and that it's you know a
brand new world in a way and they're
just not they're not assuring themselves
into it and that's that's the problem
and then they don't listen to anybody
either so since you told me that
nothing's off topic and you already
brought him up so you mentioned so your
part you say partner
what's a partner is a partner that
always reminds me my boyfriend boyfriend
but partner always seems like you're
playing tennis do you boyfriend play
golf or something or he was a boyfriend
for two years and now it's been going on
eleven he's a partner now yeah he moved
it to partner he's partner fair enough
so no my husband so he's a Bernie guy
and I was running obviously you're not
and I think that's super interesting we
had dinner one night the four of us and
I did
we're interesting because I get a lot of
email from people that are breaking up
over this kind of stuff right other
marriages I've had people email me that
they have had divorces or are in the
midst of a divorce because of this yeah
you guys can some help sir work past
that I think look because politics are
not the B Lynn though even though many
people might feel that way in in this
crazy environment and atmosphere that
we're living in I won't allow it I
simply won't allow it and I don't think
he will allow it either I mean in terms
we like each other more than that right
but is that generally easier first from
do you think someone coming from your
perspective then usually the leftist
percent we don't have to make this about
your boyfriend specifically your partner
but you know to me like I find people
that are coming from it from a Moroso
politics is in everything perspective
can let a lot of stuff go versus oh yeah
a lot of lefties they think politics is
everything right they believe that this
thing is everything look I am of that of
that of that demo I will not let
politics destroy a relationship and I
will not let it destroy a friendship at
all I had dinner last night with three
friends who are on the right who were
conservative I'm having dinner tomorrow
night with three friends who are
Democrat and heavily SoCal liberals I
moved through both worlds and I will
never define a friend or not have a
friend based on what their politics are
I simply won't do it don't disinvite
someone a bit based on their fathers as
absurd though of course this has
happened and it's happened to me through
this book and through my podcast even
though I am NOT a vocal trump supporter
and I what I do is I I've been
criticized in the media and I've been
criticizing people have been losing
their minds over Trump that gets you
disinvited yeah a lot of stuff so that
be clear you yeah you mean you talk
about since you didn't even vote for
Trump right but so much related to it's
not enough yeah it's not enough you have
to call your face off you have to call
your face off but anyway I have to say
and and it would have be absurd to me if
I lost my relationship with my boyfriend
over politics I think that would be
absurd yet it's come close it's come
close at times certainly the summer of
2018 when everything looked like it was
blowing up and the Cavanaugh hearings
were happening and
we were on separate sides though I
thought the counter hearings were a joke
a complete joke he thought she was a
hero
heroin a heroin that I thought was
insane I thought it was absolutely
insane and so we did get to a couple of
you know whisper screaming arguments and
in pavilions or whatever you know it was
just nuts and I was I could barely drive
the car because we were screaming at
each other over this and I couldn't
believe how fast it would come on it
wasn't a slow burn it will go 100 in
like five seconds and you're screaming
at each other over this you cannot
believe that one person is you at the
same time you know you take a deep
breath and you realize what is this
about what is this about and I and I
will say I am the more mature one I
don't say anything anymore
I just keep it closed and lock it up and
say you're the more mature he was saying
some things about Bernie yeah about
Trump but just like maybe you know so I
am I'm but I can't imagine letting
politics to find not only my love life
or my friendships yeah not gonna happen
so all the people that when they've gone
crazy one of the guys who helped frame
some of this for me do you know Michael
malleus by any chance I don't know if it
is it he's an interesting guy you'd like
a lot he's a he's really sort of a he's
even a firt he's not even a libertarian
he's more of like an an cap you know no
government he like he likes kind of
chaos like I calm the Willy walk of
politics he's just kind of outright a
really really interesting thinker but he
loves the tumult that we're in right now
uh-huh where I think my default is a
little more if everyone could just calm
down yeah that's a little bit better oh
yeah but I but I would imagine though
also as a writer and generally as a
creative person it's like you kind of
have to like it a little bit if you're
gonna be able to get anything done right
I think like if you were hating this
entire thing right now do you think you
could be creative through it I actually
do hate a lot of it yeah I really do
hate a lot of it and I and it's not it's
not again beside that elected Trump that
I hate I really do hate what's become of
the other side of the aisle that's
really my problem and that's what makes
me so sad and depressing me all the time
is that there is this complete absence
of
of connection of wanting to connect and
wanting to stem this divide that's
happening wanting to mend meant
something and I do think that the media
is at fault a huge part of his at fault
I don't think brush and box are there to
blame for anything the media must be
blamed for really sowing the seeds of
just discord and the fact that my
friends on the Left cannot speak to
somebody often on the right is a problem
I think there was some poll taken where
92% of people on the right would have
yeah a little over 8% of liberals would
have a conservative whatever that is I
really do see that I see that around LA
and I see that around the people that I
know in New York that that actually
makes me depressed that is a depressing
thing it doesn't make me happy to be
alive or to be a writer
and a lot of what I'm writing right now
really has nothing to do with any of
this I'm writing a novel that said in
1980 I am writing another novel is based
on an intellectual property so I don't
know if there's anything about this
period but I necessarily want to write
write about I do think that it is kind
of a very depressing stressful period to
a degree I'm a lot older so I kind of
let it go up run off me but you know
there is stress floating around
everywhere yeah are you surprised how
its worldwide now that it feel it's not
just you know little la bubble it's not
just a little American thing but it
seems to be everywhere now well look I
was surprised that this book was being
published in as many countries as it was
because it's nonfiction and it seems to
be specifically about the United States
and what's been going on the last five
or 10 years here culturally politically
to a degree but I did two tours of
France for this book because they see
the same thing kind of happening Kancil
culture is rearing its head political
correctness to an almost frightening
degree and a cultural appropriation is
starting to also rear its head the me to
movement is being weaponized in ways
that go against whatever its initial
promise was when it began and a lot of
people were getting
worried certainly when I was touring
through Italy of all places the same
concerns that all of the these things
that we're talking about here is kind of
sweeping along Europe at least
throughout Europe and that nationalism
for another thing is sweeping along
Europe as well which of course drives
you know your average liberal plate
insane but look but but also I mean what
is being recorded I mean what is being
recorded or reported I mean you know the
elections in Israel happen the last few
days can your cricket if about anything
about the novel I mean anything right
and it seems I mean and the way the
headlines were in the New York Times and
the LA Times were might be looks like it
instead of like you know decisively
saying that this has happened so I I
don't know I mean I think we're in a
very weird place in terms of how we're
getting our information and how we're
getting our Meishan from everywhere so
like you're saying yes around the world
this whatever this might be yeah it's
happening do you think maybe we're
starting to enter a time when we won't
need institutions the way we needed them
so you mentioned the New York Times and
CNN before these things that core
pillars that we all believed in and
maybe that's part of why but other
people are just like yes and it's all
becoming neat I'm seeing so much [ __ ]
drop away from me so much stuff that I
used to believe in that I used to watch
that I used to read just dropping away
from me because of really most of the
time a kind of bias that I smell and I
can't deal with so I find a lot of that
just dropping away from me so yes this
is a risk though if they all crumble
well interesting what's the risk well
the risk being that if all the
institutions crumble the things that
sort of link us to something kind of
mainstream that the Overton Window will
be is so blown away that we're just
gonna have factions of people constantly
warring over what is actually true
because there will be no institutions
that are able to thank you
you know I do think that's happening and
I've started to come to believe that
that is the only alternative but but I
do think maybe for a democracy to work
you still need usually sort of function
you think having the New York Times
being no I'm not really no understand
the grey lady country is really healthy
I don't know I don't either
I usually don't and I think it's I just
wonder if I just wonder in the absence
of all institutions as we watch colleges
crumble and universities which should
probably rightly crumble to and we watch
the media establishment crumble and a
political we're watching the Democratic
Party crumble in front of our eyes I
think well what comes after you know I
think easier for younger people perhaps
who who did not grow up like us with for
a long time a belief in these
institutions Todd yeah that's the heart
of what I'm asking right because again
my partner is very easily more adaptable
to a wide range of places to get his
information and I don't even think he
reads the New York Times but he but also
his antenna has been I don't know
sharpened during the last three years to
I remember that and he has gone to many
many different sources to get his
information and I remembered there was a
moment the week of the Mullen report
when it came out and he was so excited
he had been fed these conspiracy
theorists by Rachel Maddow for three
years been sitting there at six o'clock
here California time waiting for Rachel
to come on and you know and and the
mother report was going to come out and
it was going to completely justify all
report well that night happened and I
remember how quiet it was in the house
and I remember that he did not turn on
MSNBC for about five days did not turn
or not and grumbled about it to me he
said of you know God what was I thinking
Alcon dissing me a god I wasted so much
time listening to this all of them and
that was really the beginning where I
noticed that he was beginning to get his
news from
a wide variety of places that were
extremely niche YouTube social media
he's fine with that I still have a
frustration with the fact that these
these structures that I believed in for
so long
are no longer trustworthy yeah and so
for me for him it's a shrug for me it's
like kind of a bit of a moral rappeling
yeah well I think that maybe that is
just this and that's what I mean by
we're sort of like this last generation
that grew up pre-internet
right something like that the Gen Xers
so it's like we still have an affinity
for percent amount of old things and all
I do and they weren't all bad the New
York Times wasn't always bad no no no no
so to watch it go to where it's gone
it's disturbing yeah it is disturbing
and and so I'm so but I have kind of
gotten over that to the degree that I've
gotten over CNN and now look at it but
but it's very hard to then get your news
you know you build your own new yeah
feeds basically but you know what I was
never that person so I really do look at
both sides cause if you look at my
Twitter feed I'm looking at stuff from
the left from the right from all over
the place and I'm interested in how
people define the news that's important
to them and what they feel is vital and
what they don't and so again that thing
about you know the Israeli elections or
whether it's about how woke Invisible
Man is the movie that came out of this
last weekend we're not woke it is I mean
I'm interested in both sides of the
story and I both sides of the aisle and
I feel that that is missing from so many
people now but they only want to hear
the narrative that verifies their belief
rather than being open to the
possibilities of being wrong of maybe
I'm or not being wrong but just maybe
that's not how I feel about something
I've always wanted that my entire life
that's what I've always wanted I wanted
to hear the other side of the story and
maybe I'm just old enough to still be
that guy I don't know
certainly my boyfriend feels that way he
wants to be validated yeah that could be
adjusted Jen Jen you're not that off
Generation Y's but yeah there could be
just a certain amount of years
separating that yeah yeah all right
let's put politics yeah anything else to
say about politics let's spend the
remaining time doing something that's a
little more in your direct we are
just sort of movies in general yeah the
state of art and things like that
I watched two movies this weekend yes
what I thought was this most bizarre
strange I could not figure out if I
liked it or hated it or even if it was a
full movie I don't even remember what
it's called it was color of something
with Nicolas Cage color out a color out
of space face yeah did you see this bye
okay so it doesn't I won't even go do it
but it was such a it was a complete like
cluster of insanity but I was like
someone made this movie that is sane I
can't believe it and then I watched
uncut gems yeah did you see that movie
yeah I thought it was absolutely
wickedly brilliant and almost perfect
the pacing music everything yeah and and
I when we finished watching it I was
like and I hadn't really had heard a
tiny bit about it I didn't know what we
were watching so it's like really nice
when you know nothing about a movie and
they have this kind of blows you away I
anyway say all of that to say I haven't
had that experience in a while where I
just turned on something and I just
loved it what do you make of the state
of movies right now in the state of art
and the things that we're getting well
because first of all that's very rare to
find a movie as well done as uncut gems
it's not like there are 150 of them that
come out every year they just simply
don't most years are bad years for
movies and that is true from 1968 to
1976 through 1989 whatever they're great
years for movies in 1999 is a famously
great year for films and this is what
was $99.99 was everything from magnolias
to American Beauty to Fight Club to just
an explosion of kind of indie movies
that were also at movie stars and we're
big scale big scale event yeah
and so but but but I think part of the
problem is that most movies aren't great
and it is a very hit-or-miss medium in
terms of something achieving you know
something as greatness or even they kind
of enjoy the enjoyable movie
Jameses is a rare thing to do what do I
think I think I think that I am just
going with the flow I think that last
year was a very very good year for
movies and I have a podcast about films
and about culture and I usually spend
most of my time the last five years
since I started this podcast in 2013
complaining about the yeren movies this
past year I couldn't it was a really
good year for movies and uncut gems was
one of those movies but you know a lot
of the time and I see a lot of movies it
is color out of space it is Nic Cage you
know unleash that guy what do what does
anyone know what happened cuz even watch
I know I guess he lost all his money and
then you know I don't know what exactly
happened but the movie
the plot everything about it was such a
it was such a mess I was like this is
either the most brilliant thing I've
ever seen or the worst movie like there
was no in-between with this thing but
but more poorly watching him it's like
what's happening to this okay you
understand Nic Cage started out as a
weirdo in the early 80s in movies like
even in valley girl yeah his first he
was this outside and I don't think
people remember vampires kiss which was
a movie where he played a literary agent
in New York who thought he was a vampire
or became a vampire a whacko nutjobs
formas a lot of people remember his
performance in Peggy Sue got married
as a performance that marred that movie
because it was so bizarre and even
Coppola who directed beggar's who got
married was thinking what are you doing
include and even the co-star Kathleen
Turner was going who am i acting with
her so we've got to understand that Nic
Cage has been this kind of actor for
many many many years and even the movie
that he won the Oscar for leaving Las
Vegas was a kind of weird
offbeat performance about a guy who
drinks himself to death in Las Vegas so
I don't know I think what's happened is
that he's felt a lot more free in terms
of expressing his inner freak and that
can be a healthy thing or not I know he
needs to make money and I know that he
did lose all of his money and that he
has he will you know do a movie if you
write the check yeah which is about a
minimum by the way he sometimes good we
have to understand he's not he was
really good in the movie called Mandy Oh
the other one there there was a tech
could have bought both but maybe works
Heller out of space doesn't work the
whole time I was like maybe this is the
best performance I've ever seen
something about him that I was like I
can't stop thinkin okay just hit or miss
and he's miss in Colorado space so I
know that Cage fans are gonna Castle
over Nick Cage believe me there's but
I'm but but so I don't know I mean look
I have a belief in the medium I want to
make movies I'm going to direct
something soon so I really do believe in
the medium but again were older and
movies still have this patina of
something about them that I still find
special even though I find myself
constantly disappointed by them to a
certain degree so I'm and especially
after a year like last year when there
was like I thought 12 or 13 terrific
movies released by the studio's I'm I'm
still a believer so as a guy that is a
believer when you see fan films popping
up all over YouTube and like for me Star
Wars was just so mangled and beaten at
this point and wrecked and yet I watched
these little fan films that people make
these little 10-minute things that's
true and there are beautiful and there
and there and the the tech and the
inertial effects are all great I know
man Kathleen Kennedy or whoever's
running it now give it to these people
does that stuff inspire you to a degree
but a lot of that cannot sustain a
two-hour movie a lot of these fan films
are very sweet and I get caught up in
them as well
yeah but they are not enough to sustain
a full-fledged movie and all the working
parts that you have to think about when
you're putting together a proper piece
of cinematic entertainment whatever that
is I sound like a old school call but
it's true and I think this is a very
interesting thing that happens among
people my partner's age she's a
millennial he's 33 is that there is
something about crafts that they don't
necessarily care about craftsmanship is
old-school craftsmanship is Empire
Empire back to the 20th century I think
that's a mistake
I think craft is a big part of why a lot
of things work
I think style is a big part of why
things work and I think that all of this
is kind of taking place in a kind of
style free zone that really doesn't care
about aesthetics but it's about ideology
and it's also about either the I mean a
fan a fan film these movies that we see
are really based on you know your
feelings of nostalgia or sentimentality
over a particular work of movies it's
not its own thing it's not creating your
own reflection of that to a degree it's
kind of stealing from the movie and
recreating it you know in in a way with
music or whatever so I don't know that
seems to me to be a little bit of a
problem and that's why I also don't find
them that interesting I can watch a few
and then I watch a few and I'm doing
cardio and then I'm like well you're
right but you're right but there's
something there it's like it's at least
at least it's something where I go to so
many movies now oh my god they're sold
there's nothing there that is true and
so your your right to degree why not
just hand them off to these people
because they can't do any worse than the
people who are making them down yeah
dude does Hollywood ever get out of this
thing or do you think it's just or is
that the same symptom of this sort of
institutional crumble well I do see that
something interesting has happened is
that the director the authorial voice is
being wiped away in Hollywood is
especially being wiped away by the
Marvel movies and about by the Star Wars
movies yeah that's actually what I
wanted to ask you next about about just
new stories cuz I feel like when I have
now like Star Wars to me feels ABS and
this is my whole house at Star Wars like
I love Star Wars so much of my ethos is
from Star Wars but like that it feels
dead to me now Marvel movies like with
the last Avengers they just it they
killed it it really took you this long
yeah like it's enough already we need
new stories that's the thought that both
of those movies when they ended I was
like give me something new not the same
you know like I've had it with these
heroes I've had it with all this stuff I
was feeling this a lot longer than you
Raisa Skywalker and of endgame were the
ones that made yeah you do have a couple
years on me that's well yes yeah I do
and I was never Star Wars person but but
generally speaking that that concept of
needing new stories we're so much of
whoa it's not story yeah it's the people
telling them hmm it's not the story I
think if you had gotten really terrific
directors with signature Styles who were
dropped into the Star Wars world maybe
they could make marvelous movies but I
don't think that's the corporate
directed Star Wars has become a
corporation and I know that people have
been fired from movies before because
they've brought a little bit too much
attitude a little bit too much of their
own spice into the movies I remember the
whole controversy about a solo that
standalone Han Solo as a young guy yeah
be where the directors were replaced by
Ron Howard at a certain point because
they were bringing too much of a comedic
edge into that film and that is that
seems to be the case where the brand is
more important than who is kind of
telling the story in a way they want the
brand to stay on topic and they don't
want it to veer too much out of a
certain corporate theme I think this is
the same way I don't think JJ Abrams
drink to anything particularly special
to the Star Wars movies compared to
other people do you think so
I think scene Rises Skywalker I did not
see it so I read I walked out of my
Johnson movie that was pilot and I never
to go see you know that made Colorado
lines or whatever the whole movie I saw
it looks like the wind exactly
Rhys Carver is fine but yes
did he just tied it up it was just like
we have such a mess here he came in and
he was just like let's just tie this
thing up so we can just right and still
you know yeah and also the same thing is
I mean true with the Marvel movies is I
mean they all feel basically the same I
mean realize they try to cancel every
director that says this right because
those in the director every now like
Coppola or somebody will come out and
say this every
yes Chris AZ says that a lot of trouble
for it he's he's essentially right to a
certain degree but I do think that those
movies of course offer huge audiences a
lot of pleasure and you can't deny that
and you do sound like a bit of a grump
in terms of proclaiming that Marvel
movies aren't cinema I think a lot I
think they are cinema I think cinema
encompasses the fan films that you and I
were just talking about and to David
Lynch's 24-hour or whatever version of
Twin Peaks that he put on what was it
Showtime three years ago
that's cinema to a lot of things were
cinema a lot of things are cinema a lot
of things are conversation we're out of
time
well thanks for havin tin you this over
dinner we'll see if we I would love
convert your partner boyfriend yeah to
the dark side yeah now we've really tied
it together
I hope so to follow this man he makes
sense at Bret Easton Ellis on the
Twitter if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell